so let's talk about president biden he's
looking to win back disillusioned young
voters before the midterms with what
some lawmakers are calling a bribe a new
report suggests that his administration
is mulling a plan to pause student loan
repayments as well as forgive ten
thousand dollars in debt
but there is growing evidence that
americans are starting to question if
college is even worth the cost only 55
percent of people say getting a degree
has a had a positive impact on the
country and that's down 14 points from
2020.
i don't know dana is there a major in
influencing on social media where do you
go to get that degree
i still think that if you look over time
having a college degree over your
lifetime at this point
shows that you would
grow more wealth in your life over time
however i think the reason you see those
numbers go down so much since 2020 is
look at what happened in academia and
parents are watching their kids come
home going wait what did you just learn
there and it's like four years of
disneyland and so it's it's not good
enough and we're not able to compete
with the rest of the world if we keep up
that pace and there are really great
ways to stay educated going forward
especially even in today like there's so
many different ways through youtube
podcasts things like that i still though
i understand why a family would want
their kid to go to college
but i also understand political
realignments we're in the middle of one
and you're watching republicans garner
all the support of the working class and
increasingly of minority populations and
one of the reasons is because they are
they are saying we are going to be for
you the democrats are increasingly
becoming the party of the college
educated and the college-educated are
more wealthy so biden is going to try to
tell us today that we're not in a
recession
that the jobs market is so strong they
don't have anything to worry about but
the
rich relatively rich
students who are now working apparently
they've got a great job market they
can't pay their student loan and it's
costing all of us six billion dollars a
month in order to pay for those student
loan servicing so all of us are getting
screwed over in this deal and the
president can't just make a decision
because the left is giving him such a
hard time so he is every two months he
has to re-up the situation i think it's
a terrible thing for the country but
it's really bad for the democratic party
in the long run
she sounds great and delicious
i will uh special
geraldo i i don't know does forgiveness
equal votes where does it end aoc warned
the president that if he didn't forgive
some of the student debt that down the
line he would kind of alienate young
democrats without being overly wonky i
think that
first of all it's unfair to everyone who
has paid their student loans off over
the generations so i think there's a
question of equity also
you forgive it now what about next
year's students and the year after that
in the year do you keep forgiving
because you forgave it in
in 2022
i think that
questioning whether or not a college
education is worth it is is a real issue
for many families uh i told the story of
how i brought this brass
chair back from africa welders came kids
just out of high school making 85 000 a
year to start for with a high school
degree so i think that you have to
consider i i think community colleges
should be vastly expanded but in terms
of whether or not this is a bribe it's a
bribe but the these kids won't remember
it won't be that oh i got to pay back
yeah but there's
he's not going to decide till the end of
august i mean
midterm elections
i think i think college is often a scam
but it's all those lawns all those
fountains all those swimming pools all
those parks uh you know someone's paying
for it so jesse in your world um did you
uh get a job in what you majored in
uh i am not a history professor so no
okay
but you know i i i'm pro-college if
that's a controversial opinion i really
don't care i just feel bad for jill
biden could you imagine being married to
joe the guy can't make a decision
rosanna he's been mulling the student
loan cancellation for his entire
presidency
joe biden is considering it do it
already like it's like joe did you make
a dinner reservation i'm still mulling
where we're gonna go i mean i'm starving
let's go
this is the situation if you want to
talk inflation
it used to cost about 150 000 for
four-year tuition it cost now 300 000 to
go to school for four years
a pr a degree can't cost more than a
home he's always job owning all these
big meat big oil you guys gotta lower
your prices why doesn't he get these
university presidents together and say
guys like
does the middlebury ski team need a
separate weight room for the transgender
students
no yes they don't need to build a
separate weight room for the transgender
ski students
they have a 1.5 billion dollar endowment
at middlebury
you're saying you keep raising tuition
it's crazy well listen greg what's ten
thousand dollars among friends i mean
it's as as you heard what college
tuition is ten thousand dollars is a
drop in the bucket first why send your
kids to college or you're loving kids to
college when they return turning against
you and biology you're actually ruining
brains to geraldo's point all the people
who paid off their student loans
and they probably work nights to do it
this is a slap in their face this is
like being at a restaurant and ordering
your dessert and then eating it and
paying for it and then suddenly they
announce a pie eating contest
you know what i mean so you're getting i
hate when that happens you're getting
american taxpayers to pay for a gift
that benefits democrats who don't need
it so this isn't like welfare or
unemployment or food stamps it's a gift
that you and i pay that is given to
upper class white art history majors who
can then
spend that money they would have spent
on the on the on the loan on holidays in
the hamptons so my solution is if you
want to forgive that stupid debt take it
from the colleges since they've tripled
the tuition the last 30 years and their
education sucks do not take it with us
because i swear to god if you do you
will see a real insurrection you're
actually stealing money you're stealing
money from people and giving it to
people this is redistribution but it's
not even going to the poor
he's actually taking money from people
to bribe people to vote for him this is
a this is a moral wrong this is the
worst thing i this gets me so mad i've
never seen you this upset every time i
think every time i think about this it
just it makes me so angry because it's
just it's actual theft
and they think they can get away with it
by saying oh it's only 10 grand here and
it's only this oh these students they
can't afford it oh they can afford it if
you can afford a car payment you can
afford your college payment it's roughly
the same like two averages like 250 270
give it to the truck drivers to pay off
their payments you dope so disgusting
you make me sick and i don't even know
who i'm talking to
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else